التغذيه العسكريه الاوكرانيا والتي تمت
بالتنقيط قد تكون ساهمت بالتقليل من
مكاسبها السريعه او المحافظه عليها
فالاتحاد الاوروبي يدين باعتذار لاوكرانيا
ورئيسها لبطئه بشكل صادم في تعبئه مواردها
وفق صحيفه ديل التلغراف البريطانيه ففي
وقت سارى دول عده لتقديم المساعده
كابولندا بريطانيا والولايات المتحده
تلكات دول اخرى وكان ردها بطيء للغايه على
طلبات زيلينسكي اليائسه والمتكرره الدعم
العسكري الغربي لاوكرانيا تمثل بالقذائف
والصواريخ اولا ثم مركبات مدره ومجموعه من
الدبابات وصولا الان ربما للمقاتلات
تيليجراف اكدت امتلاك تحالف النيتو لاليات
مشتركه ولكنه ببساطه لا يستخدمها مبديه
ضروره مراجعه هذه الدول لمعدل انفاقها على
الحرب وطالما ان الحرب لن تبقى في
اوكرانيا
وفق هذه الصحيفه
الانظمه المصممه لحمايه العاصمه الروسيه
من هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار تحبط الانشطه
اليوميه للسكان وباتت محور الشكاوى
الرياضيين وحتى سائقي سيارات الاجره حيث
عطلت معدات التشويش نظام تحديد المواقع
العالمي gps وسط موسكو وكذلك الساعات
الذكيه وبالتالي عرقل التطلعات اكثر من 20
الف عداء في نصف مره موسكو الاسبوع الماضي
للتغلب على افضل الاوقات الشخصيه فمتتبع
السرعه والمسافه فشلوا بمتابعه الرياضيين
بعد تجاوز اثر كذلك على تطبيق استدعاء
سيارات الاجره وتنظيم عمليات النقل بين
السائقين والركب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات